proposers this weekend Trump is heading
to the g7 summit a meeting of the top
economic powers in the world not to be
confused with the Furious 7 summit a
meeting of the top Vin Diesel fans in
the world
that's where Don junior will be this
year the g7 is being held in America's
most dangerous enemy Canada a country
that Trump recently slapped with some
long-overdue very badass economic
sanctions for reasons of national
security now the line media would have
you believe that Trump is being
ridiculous that Canada is an ally and
the world's greatest source of hot riots
but they are good-looking riots we know
the truth Canada is hanging over
America's head like a maple scented
sword of Damocles and Trump's done
playing nice president Trump and
Canadian Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
according to our sources wolf had a
testy phone call late last month over
new tariffs imposed by the Trump
administration Trudeau pressed the
President on how he could justify these
tariffs as a national security issue in
response a wolf we're told mr. Trump
quipped to Trudeau
didn't you guys burn down the White
House this was an apparent reference to
the war of 1812 yeah that's right Rob
don't let that go
tanana did burn down the White House in
1812 and we have the footage to prove it
man
the past was so high death and in 1812
that was our only helicopter and even
though nerdy historians are quick to
point out that Canada didn't burn down
the White House that it was in fact
British forces that set the fire and
that the reason they did it was
ironically because of a trade dispute
fact checkers be damned
I'm with Trump on this one hey Canada
you think Trump was gonna let this thing
slide Trump doesn't let anything slide
he doesn't even let himself slide no too
dangerous there could be sharks down
there Trump knows that those who forget
the past are doomed to be hit with steel
and aluminum tariffs 200 years later
during peacetime hey Canada is still
attacking us just this month they
dispatched one of their rhyming Mounties
with a dope fade to her ass one of
America's finest unregulated
pharmaceutical pushers displace and
slide Canadian operatives are pulling
off attacks like this every day
don't let Prime Minister AB sway you our
soldiers who had fought and died
together on the beaches of World War two
on the mountains of Afghanistan this is
insulting to them the idea that we are
somehow a national security threat to
the United States is quite frankly
insulting and unacceptable you know I
will tell you what's insulting having a
national anthem that doesn't mention
bombs once
what you think these tariffs were
politically convenient for Trump and he
called you a national security threat
because it's the easiest reason to enact
them please you believe that we got a
Stanley Cup to sell you seriously we
keep winning it from you and we don't
care about hockey at all it's
embarrassing
just take it we'll give it to you for
basically nothing opposers the fact is
trump is heading into enemy territory
this weekend so President Trump I know
you're watching might I recommend going
to our online store the shop position
calm and picking up our Canadian War
prep kit complete with geese distraction
crumbs a bottle of good tasting American
ketchup and a specialized anti
politeness flak jacket that can stop it
I'm Surrey at close range
so Godspeed Trump go show Canada what
you can't do the fight continued the
fight continues good you hit down here
with the real truth lies you want to
help me defeat the globalists and stay
on the inside click and subscribe and
help me defeat them because following me
on my youtube channel makes you a leader
it tracks trust me